عندما كنت مراهقًا في السبعينيات من القرن الماضي ،
كان والداي يعانيان من القلق الطبيعي حينها ، وهو
الإفراط في شرب الخمر أثناء
حمل المراهقات وتدخين كل من السجائر
والأعشاب الضارة ،
لكن المخاوف الرئيسية لآباء اليوم
بشأن أبنائهم المراهقين هم من
نوع مختلف من القلق والاكتئاب
الذاتي-  تؤذي الانتحار ،
هذه الإحصائيات المزعجة تسبق
الوباء ، وقد ازدادت سوءًا
منذ عام 2019 ، أفاد 13 بالمائة من المراهقين
بأنهم تعرضوا لنوبة اكتئاب كبيرة
بزيادة 60 بالمائة عن عام
2007.  حتى عام 2018 ووفقًا
للنصوص السريعة للصيدلة عبر البريد من 2015 إلى 2019 ، ارتفعت الوصفات الطبية
لمضادات الاكتئاب 38
للمراهقين مقارنة بـ 15 في المائة للبالغين
، وتشكل هذه الحقائق أكثر
خلفية الجزء الأول من
الجائحة الداخلية ، سلسلة نيويورك تايمز
حول المراهقة بعنوان  إنها حياة أو
موت ، أزمة الصحة العقلية بين
المراهقين الأمريكيين الذين انضموا إلي الآن هو مؤلفها  مات
ريتشتل ، كاتب فريق حائز على جائزة بوليتزر
في نيويورك تايمز
للمسلسل الذي أمضى أكثر من عام في
مقابلة المراهقين
وعائلاتهم ، كما كتب كتابًا
أطلق عليه للتو فهم
الإبداع الملهم رحلة عبر علم الفن
والروح مات كما أنا  قال يا رفاقي
إنهم قلقون للغاية بشأن
عودتي إلى المنزل من برغر ، ما تغير
بشكل جيد ، أعتقد أن سؤالي الأول هو هل كانوا على
حق في القلق ،
نعم
حسنًا ، انظروا ، لقد كان لدينا
تحول أساسي
في الولايات المتحدة
ويبدو أنه عبر  الدول الغربية
فيما تعانيه
الصحة العامة للشباب قلقة من تلك
الأضرار الخارجية التي ذكرتها من قبل
وانقلبت الأمور وهم الآن
قلقون بشأن ما يسمونه هذه
المخاطر الداخلية
القلق والاكتئاب الانتحار وإيذاء النفس
هذه قصة وحشية للصحة العامة
هي أن هذه الأشياء  كانوا دائمًا
معنا ولكن عندما لم يتم تشخيصي أو
كان هناك نوع من التحول وإذا كان الأمر كذلك
بسبب ما
أعنيه فهو  إجابة غريبة ولكن
الإجابة هي نعم ، وربما
كان هناك بعض هذه الأشياء وبعضها
تم
تكثيفها ، والأسباب الكامنة وراءها معقدة بعض الشيء ،
لكنني سأحاول تضييقها على
هذا ، حيث
حدث تغيير في
دماغ المراهق و  أدى التغيير في
البيئة وتصادم هذين
الأمرين إلى تضخيم ما نفكر فيه عندما كنا
سن المراهقة قلقًا وحولته في بعض الحالات
إلى علم أمراض خطير ،
وهنا بعض الأشياء التي
سأضعها في شكل رسم بياني من
مقالتك.  التي هي في الأسفل
، فلنلقِ نظرة على هذه ،
فهي تشمل ما يلي:
ما إذا كان الأشخاص قد دخنوا في أي وقت مضى حاولوا التدخين الإلكتروني -
الفيبينج - كحول غير محمي ،
ومشاهدة التليفزيون ، فأنت تعتقد أنه
من الجيد أن تكون هذه الأشياء في الشريحة التالية ، من
فضلك ، إليك بعض الأشياء
التي حدثت  أو على الأقل تزداد سوءًا ،
فهي تشمل الشعور المستمر بالحزن أو
اليأس والتفكير بجدية في الانتحار
حتى وضع خطة لمحاولة الانتحار
وما إلى ذلك ، شريحة أخرى إذا كان بإمكاني استخدام
الهاتف الذكي  العمر ، ما هو الرابط
بين هذه الشرائح الثلاثة التي
عرضتها للتو ،
لذا أعني أولاً وقبل كل شيء أنت سعيد جدًا
لأنك اخترتها لأنهم
أظهروها بعبارات واضحة جدًا
ما يحدث وما هو
الهاتف الذكي  لا يمثل
الهاتف الذكي في حد ذاته
، ومن السهل أن نقول إن صعود
الهاتف الذكي والإنترنت تسبب في هذا ،
ولكن إليك طريقة أخرى للتفكير في
ذلك michael
الذي يمثل تحولًا هائلاً في
نمط الحياة ، حيث انتقل نمط الحياة من
الهواء الطلق إلى الخارج في
الآباء القلقون بشأن البرميل الذي
يشعر به والداي ربما
يقودان السيارة بتهور ، لكنهما
يتجمعان في نمط حياة يكون فيه
الشباب في الداخل بشكل متزايد ،
حيث يحصلون على تمارين بدنية
أقل ، وتجربة
شخصية أقل ، كما أنهم ينامون أقل ويتفاعلون
مع أجهزتهم  هذا لا يعني أن
الهاتف الذكي هو السبب ، بل يعني أن
الهاتف الذكي هو نقطة انعطاف في
نمط الحياة المتغير